the european border and coast guard or
frontex
uses unmarked vehicles to patrol a
heavily fenced section of the greek
turkish border
they are the human element among
increasingly sophisticated european
surveillance technologies being tested
here
such as these pillar mounted cameras
capable of penetrating kilometers into
turkish territory
day and night
camera monitoring is automated through a
program that processes the images
recognizes what is approaching and
sounds the alarm it mainly distinguishes
people and vehicles which is what
concerns us in cross-border crime
the crime in question is a legal entry
from turkey
including crossings by refugees from the
banks of the everest river which
separates the two countries
fifteen of these cameras will monitor
the entire 200 kilometer length of the
greek turkish border by the end of the
year
they can detect people hiding behind
trees and bushes
and they're supplemented by radar
unmanned aerial vehicles and ground
sensors
surveillance was stepped up after march
last year when turkey reneged on an
agreement to hold back refugees from the
european union
instead it encouraged them to storm the
greek border
but security concerns go back much
further
in 2010 36 000 people entered greece
illegally
across the land border with turkey 26
000 of them
along the 12 kilometer stretch behind me
two years later
the greek armed forces erected a double
chain link fence
three meters tall along these 12
kilometers
and after last year's events that fence
was reinforced
with the five meter tall steel palisade
you see behind me
and there may be more sinister methods
being used to deter
crossings refugees captured this video
on their mobile phones in september
2018.
they say it shows greek border guards
depositing them
on the turkish side of the river after
they attempted to cross into greece
such pushbacks are illegal under the
geneva convention
authorities are supposed to allow
refugees to apply for asylum
forensic architecture an independent
research team at goldsmiths university
in london
used 3d modelling to identify the
precise location of this
and other alleged pushbacks along the
everest and says
there is a set pattern once illegal
entrants are arrested in greece
people are then held there for hours
upon end
until it gets dark
when they are loaded onto military style
trucks or vans again driven to the banks
of the river
and loaded onto smaller dinghies
until eu members agree to share the
burden of asylum
greece is obliged to absorb any refugees
that come its way
and is likely to continue its policy of
deterrence
john cerropolos al jazeera along the
everest river